and assassin's creed 3 otherwise known
as assassins creed America now we went
in there it wasn't a playable demo again
it was just like the last of us they had
someone play in the game we were
watching in the theater a theater where
we were sitting on box crates because
they're legit like that but I got to say
this game is absurdly entertaining it's
really impressive Assassin's Creed 3
takes place during the Revolutionary War
so little did we all know John Adams and
Thomas Jefferson George Washington they
all had a little bit of help a little
bit of help called assassins I saw
someone fight someone he took the guy's
head and planted it grew a pitchfork
that was in a weapon rack where wasn't
he was just now he's there now he's dead
stuff like that just impresses the hell
out of me you can take a bayonet stab it
into someone pull the trigger shoot the
guy behind him I mean if you love
Assassin's Creed it's like assassin's
creed ii x otherwise known as assassins
creed mirka
and they have a hiding system now you
hide in bushes and plants it kind of
reminded me of Metal Gear Solid free
Snake Eater you hide in the bushes you
try to blend in people don't see you
then you pop out you do it assassins do
you kill him and they incorporated the
Brotherhood in this game also a bunch of
red coats r after Connor Connors the
main antagonist in this game he calls in
the Brotherhood's Brotherhood had red
coats on they walked him right into the
right into the red coat base like they
just arrested him after that you just do
your business you do with assassins do
yeah kill in America
they get this one sweet weapon I don't
even know the name of the weapon it's
ultimately a little dagger hook on a
rope you're in a tree you snared a guy
you jump down and ultimately you just
hang the guy up to die and you just walk
away walk away like nothing happened
because that's how assassins roll all
the games should have that weapon if you
guys when you see it and when you play
it you're going to be like all games to
doubt that weapon consensus is unanimous
packs just gets better and better
there's so many games in the next year
that I'm gonna get a sorry for my bank
account for putting you into bankruptcy
but that's just how I roll because I
care about what matters which is good
games like Assassin's Creed 3
you